hello this is Kimberly Leonard at Sky
News so as we record this Sky News Daily
there are things we know and a lot we
don't know about the latest crisis at
the BBC
we know a high profile presenter has
been suspended we know the corporation
had been due to meet police to discuss
the allegations made to the Sun
that he paid thousands of pounds to a
teenager for explicit photos
their contacts started its claimed when
that individual was 17 back in 2020 but
we don't know for sure why the star
stayed in his job after the first
complaint almost two months ago we don't
know whose timeline of events since then
is correct the BBC's or the teenager's
Mom's account that she gave to the son
whatever the truth the BBC seems to be
facing its biggest scandal in years and
a huge test in the relationship it has
with its audience the people who of
course provide its funding
what damage could this do to the BBC
later we'll hear from Roger Bolton who's
a former BBC producer and presenter who
now presents the bbwatch podcast but
first let's speak to our home editor
Jason Farrell hi Jason thanks a lot for
chatting to us on this at the time of
recording this we still don't know who
this person is so I think it's worth
just going over why why is it that they
haven't said who this BBC presenter is
yeah I mean there has been a lot of
speculation about why hasn't this person
been named people are talking about it
on Twitter they want to know who this
presenter is they want confirmation but
there have been reasons and strong
reasons given so far why this person
hasn't been named it from the
perspective of the BBC why the BBC
hasn't done it Tim Davey the director
General explained in a memo to staff
yesterday actually and his reasoning was
that by law
individuals are entitled to a reasonable
expectation of privacy and certainly if
there was an employee being investigated
internally within your company for now
allegation made externally in the
initial stages that would be private
that that internal investigation and for
example if it then was a criminal
investigation it would only be when the
sort of formal criminal proceedings
started that that name would become
public and as we heard from the police
yesterday that actually hadn't been a
formal allegation made to the police as
of yesterday we know the BBC are meeting
today I think the other question is why
hasn't the Sun newspaper who's who's
brought this story to everyone's
attention why haven't they named uh that
person I heard Kelvin McKenzie a former
editor of the sun saying that he under
his ownership they would have done and
it is a decision for the the newspaper
but obviously the clear thing that they
have to worry about are the defamation
laws you know do they have enough
information do they have enough facts
out there to be absolutely clear that
what they're saying is true and I think
for all the other media Outlets who
don't have aren't privy to everything
that the sun has been privy to there
haven't been in conversations with
people making those allegations is even
more difficult you know other media
organizations can't suddenly jump to an
allegation even if they've got pretty
good idea who the son is talking about
because they don't have the information
to to protect themselves against a libel
a libel allegation if that were to come
from that individual and there's been a
change in privacy laws in recent years
hasn't there
that's right so that you want you do
have greater protection now against uh
against newspapers uh bringing out uh
your name uh in in the public in such a
in in such a way because uh you know
this this is the kind of thing as the
point has been made it can ruin careers
if uh if names come out even if the
allegations turn out down the line not
to be true
you spoke about how it's been playing
out on social media so much speculation
and that has been one of the unintended
consequences here hasn't it but people
have had to come out and defend
themselves because everyone's talking
about who it is
well I think this is the difficulty for
the BBC because not only are their own
presenters now obviously coming under
scrutiny and over the weekend various
high-profile presenters uh had to come
out and say that it wasn't them Nikki
Campbell on his on his program this
morning had to say it wasn't him Jeremy
Vine said you know I can't believe I'm
having to say this but by the fact that
I'm speaking into this microphone tells
you that it's not me because we know
that this person has been suspended and
what that means is of course that there
was already a relatively short list of
presenters who are earning a six-figure
salary as it was told by the sun this
person is there's a relatively short
list and as as each presenter comes out
and says it's not me I'm on air that
list gets shorter
Jason let's have a listen now you
mentioned Nikki Campbell you mentioned
well he spoke about the false
accusations on his BBC Radio show today
this morning in fact let's have a listen
to what he said obviously Thoughts with
the alleged victim and family so a bit
of perspective here worse things happen
at Sea as they say but it was a
distressing weekend I can't deny it for
me and others uh falsely named today I'm
having further conversations with the
police in terms of malicious
communication and with lawyers in terms
of definition defamation in terms of
defamation laws that's why Nikki
Campbell has contacted the police in
this instance
that's right I mean again it's quite
difficult the police would quite rightly
be able to look at that and see if uh if
something has been said that is
particularly egregious under a malicious
communication but then also he could go
to the Civil courts and make a liable
claim against people I think Jeremy Vine
said you know how could what can we do
you know can you make 85 different libel
claims because so many people not only
tweet it but then retweet it and that is
the problem with social media
speculation with this void of who this
person is let's talk about the police
there's meant to be a police meeting
with BBC bosses today do we have any
idea what's going to happen in that
meeting and when it's going to happen
what do we know about it well what we
know is that the BBC only contacted the
police on Friday I spoke to the met
yesterday and they said that's when they
had first Contact and I believe it was a
contact with an officer even the Met
police press office actually didn't know
about that contact initially and so they
made their statement on uh Sunday and
that was when they had an
another contact from the BBC and then
they said we will have further
conversations with the BBC and that's
obviously been happening today
and we expect that then they will go
into these criminal allegations because
what has been said in the sun is uh is
Criminal it is illegal to uh to possess
to ask for to pay for to provide images
of an explicit nature of someone who is
under 18 they cannot consent to sending
them even if they if it looks like
they've sent them themselves that that
that's the law and that's uh really the
difficult difficulty of this allegation
and what the BBC have said in defense of
why it took them two months to get to
this stage from the initial allegation
on May the 19th is that what was printed
in the sun was different to what they
were told back in may they said it was
in a different nature it was new were
their words what's your assessment of
how the BBC have handled this
I think it's really hard to assess how
the BBC have handled this at this stage
it doesn't look good that they had this
happen they that we we know and they've
they've accepted that they were told
back in May
um and it's taken this much time for a
suspension to happen so we know now that
it's serious enough what they know now
that someone has been suspended so it
doesn't look good it may be they say
that they have robust processes in place
and that they have been looking into
this since it was reported in May I
think we have to see what those
processes were whether they were
properly followed
um who knew it's it's certainly right
and proper that some people shouldn't
know when when someone is being
investigated for certain allegations but
perhaps should know if those allegations
become more serious
um they suggest they say that this is
complex the BBC say this is complex and
fast moving so there is a bit of
intrigue there as to exactly what they
mean by that is there something about
this that we don't know so I think it's
I think it's perhaps not right at this
stage to come out and criticize anyone
at this stage because we don't know
enough to say they've acted in the wrong
way but there is there's definitely two
Shadows looming in this Scandal and and
one is the anonymity of the figure but
the other is the lack of clarity at this
stage as to how the BBC have handled
what's happened
and just after I recorded with Jason two
updates from the police
the Met says it's not investigating the
case of the suspended presenter yet
that's after it met with BBC
representatives in an online call
officers are assessing the information
and making further inquiries and in the
other update they are investigating a
report of malicious Communication in
relation to a social media post there
have been no arrests
I've also been speaking to Roger Bolton
former BBC producer and presenter who
now presents the B watch podcast
this is what he told me on the BBC's
response I think it's
security for the BBC's enemies to kick
it there may be arguments about how
quickly they responded to these
allegations and we're not sure what they
were and when but they brought in the
police very early it's only seven
weeks since they've first heard about
this
so um I don't I mean it's a crisis they
may be criticized I don't think it's a
massive Scandal it would only be a
scandal if it was revealed that the BBC
knew about this person's activity and
chose not to disclose it nonetheless
it's deeply embarrassing the DG sent
that email the internal email that was
um we saw yesterday and in it he
outlined the challenges in handling this
the individual's right privacy for one
um do you think
we were talking about the timeline they
knew about it in May and then new
allegations on Thursday but do you think
they've been Swift and transparent
enough
I think it's impossible to know what I
think the BBC will have to do when this
is over is publish that and tell us what
they knew when they knew it and who knew
it
but it may be that the first things they
were told were sufficient to Modern to
explore but not not fleshed out in
detail
maybe that on Thursday when the director
General was informed and when allegedly
you know further allegations were made
the detail came out so we don't the
truth is we don't know the BBC may have
been quick it may have been slow
um but I think what's crucial is that a
timeline is published
and and this should not be difficult
there's got to be photographs if this is
true and they're going to be payments
very substantial payments and records of
them if it's true so it shouldn't take
long to find both those things and that
should really put an end to it as far as
the BBC is concerned there's a separate
question about whether their the actions
were Criminal
there may have been if the person
involved was under 18 when indecent
photographs were solicited if they were
solicited
so I think that you know
um if it's shown that payments were made
that's enough to get the person
dismissed from the BBC it's a separate
question about where there is sufficient
evidence for a criminal prosecution
one of the things that the sun alleges
was that the mother of this individual
came forward to them and didn't want any
payment for the story because she had
seen the BBC presenter on air after they
had made the allegations or they had
made um or they'd contacted the B do you
think that that presenter should have
stayed on air after May 19th you can't
just say because there's an allegation
we're going to damage your career take
you off a increase suspicions get the
press back on you you've got to have
some evidence that the the allegations
are substantial
and then you've got to decide what
you've got a responsibility the person
should be innocent and proven guilty
you've got to have that privacy respect
their privacy on the other hand you have
got to have the most rigorous
investigation so it may be that the BBC
is at fault it may be obviously didn't
pursue these things sufficiently quickly
but it may be the BBC would behave
entirely properly in this all we know is
the two things only one is you put BBC
sex and cover up in a headliner bang
often cares and that we are however much
we say we're terribly serious about this
we all want to know these things and
there's some things we should not know
until they have been substantially
supported by the evidence
the internet is a wonderful thing but
it's full of lies and it's full of
deformation in future I fear it will be
full of AI and deep deep fake videos so
we must be careful not to rush to
judgment but the BBC is paid for by the
license repairs it must be transparent
about what it's done uh and we'll see
but at the moment I think the BBC's
crisis is passing through BBC it's now
in the hands of essentially the police
and
the agent and presenter involved
and the BBC's remaining obligation I
think is to present us with a full and
detailed account of what they knew when
they knew it and what they did about it
I want to pick up on what you said about
the license fee and who pays for the BBC
do you think
this is a massive test
of trust in the BBC
well I think it's a I think it is a test
of trust but this goes on all the time
remember the BBC is highly unpopular
with a conservative party in large parts
of the media who love putting the boot
here I mean look at people like
Doris and so on all PS Morgan in any
opportunity it doesn't matter what the
evidence is kick the beam now BBC should
be kicked on occasions and I've
certainly kicked them but you know it's
an alien atmosphere it's a hostile
atmosphere to it
um but when you look at this uh the
worst they can have done in this
instance is not
um in the seven weeks since they knew
that initial
um allegation was made that they hadn't
acted quick enough that's
concerning but they know there's no
evidence they've tried to hide anything
so I do not believe this is a massive
Scandal unless you can prove either that
BBC knew about this person's activities
and did nothing
about it and let them continue to
broadcast
or if the BBC was told something about
it and then didn't take appropriate
action quickly
there's no evidence yet anyway either
there's a plot their fault quite a
massive Scandal it's unfortunate it's
uncomfortable but I'm afraid it goes
with the BBC does get kicked now and
again and occasionally deserves it but
actually can you imagine any other media
organization doing better
do you think it's going to have
ramifications on that annual report
would we due to see it tomorrow
well I think it'll be tough for the
director General to get the press's
media's attention to on anything other
than this particular issue you'll have
to deal with it out front you'll have to
make a statements from it possible but
if you were you know if if the annual
report was part of shall we say if BBC
Media uh PR offensive in which they're
trying to say well good value for money
they are and what they're doing whatever
then it's a nightmare because you know
we all know what happened tomorrow at
the press conference we all know what
the first question will be and the
second and the third
so it'll be tough because it'll go ahead
would you want to have your Executives
in that position where the the Press are
there and they can be asked anything
well first of all I'll take the view and
have all the time when I was doing
feedback already for is that that goes
really you have the license fee the
shareholders are the listeners and the
viewers and they have the right to ask
questions and you have to accept if you
get take a job top of the BBC where
you're paid less than your updates at
Channel 4 or elsewhere but still played
pretty well you've just you've got to
put up with it this is the price but I
think people should recognize that there
are very few if any organized
broadcasting organizations in the world
that are as open uh as the BBC they make
mistakes by Heaven they make mistakes
and they need a kicking occasionally
who says yes to me that this is that
serious to be honest even maybe
in three months time we'll be looking
back and wondering did we get all study
out of proportion even though
it could mean
still allegations still reportedly that
one of the biggest stars is involved in
illegal activity
yes it could do but you know human
beings are very strange I used to work
with a guy called Frank both
was the most popular presenter probably
in the country certainly one of the most
popular anywhere in the BBC he did sport
whatever sometime after he left the BBC
um he was found to go go into a brothel
dressed as a woman and taking drugs
I talked to him pretty after it they
just said he had a complete breakdown
whatever nobody could have guessed that
we're all strange we all have secrets
and to say because you've been a
presenter on the BBC it's somehow the
BBC is responsible for your private life
but you can't blame an organization that
employs somebody for that you can blame
them if they don't do due diligence and
if they don't when they're hearing of
serious concerns uh pursue them and if
they don't make it absolutely clear to
all members of their staff that that
solid behavior isn't acceptable
but I don't think any organization can
police the mind
of its presenters
we'll be back on Tuesday with more
reaction to the Fallout but for now you
can get the latest on Sky News across
our socials and on the Sky News app this
episode was produced by Annie Joyce with
Alex Eden the editor is Paul stanworth